bonjour jean salivait bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous dans la
matinale de rtl france ce matin alors
vous allez manifester demain pour quelle
raison précisément rijeka même de choses
depuis centaines portant actuellement la
venue car les retraités sont présentés
comme des gens à des situations qui sont
en ville a pourtant je vais vous montrer
c'est que le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités diminue de plus en plus sur 16
millions mendiants de répondants en
france nous en avait presque fini leur
venue en bus pour samedi parce qu'ils
sont sous le seuil de pauvreté sachant
que ce sera une loi votée il ya deux
nets 106 euros pour une personne seule
et 1407 je viens que ça ça veut bien
dire
il faut savoir également que depuis 2013
les retraites
elles ne sont pas du comment je vais où
elles sont augmentés que par petites
doses
prenons un exemple m'a gagné en 2010
nettement plus rien en 2001 il ya un
rattrapage de d à côté de ça il ya eu
des choses vont mieux jeunes il ya les
charges c'est à lyon la fiscalité sur
les retraités à cannes pendant deux lots
ces dernières années je pense à la csg
j'ai passé de presque 25 62 notation
incertain c'est certain nombre de
retraités vous savez certains qui sont
la catin la casa c'est la contribution
additionnelle sur la solidarité la
galerie l'autonomie elle est payée par
der crédit sa part porter en lui sans
oignons mais sa redescente pas toujours
seulement québec
vous avez eu des changements fiscaux
s'ils auraient regretté sur les tatamis
depuis ans trois enfants ça commence à
faire au mieux ses plus jeunes ouvrir la
lizadeel milliards aujourd'hui
alors j'ai mis ça peut aller de plus en
plus
justement il ya d'autres choses en
pleine situation sanitaire on a souvent
mis ses vrais l'accent sur les efforts
consentis aujourd'hui par la jeunesse
pour protéger votre génération comment
est ce que vous vous le vivez ça un
cuisant que je vais dire ça c'est ça ne
sert à rien de mettre les chaînes comme
khaled personnes âgées
ce qui est intéressant c'est la
configuration qui les suit je dirais la
première à une épaule elle pense ouvrir
en grand soutien de jeunesse parce que
pratiquement de tous les retraités ils
ont des enfants
les ans aussi de petits enfants bon
quand on les aide mais également de vos
places vous savez que c'est difficile
aujourd'hui d'être achevé mais ils sont
si difficile aujourd'hui d'avoir moins
de bons temps avoir des têtes le jeu
permet donc on nous force ouvrière on
porte un soutien permanent à la jeunesse
et on y rencontre le mans en ce qui
concerne la vaccination que pensez-vous
du dispositif du gouvernement est ce que
les retraités accède facilement à la
vaccination n'a vu emmanuel macron hier
inauguré un un nouveau dispositif pour
vous faciliter la tâche
qu'en pensez vous sous la vaccination
il est évident qu'à la trame de
cacophonie en france il faut calmer
trompe l'espace a trompé en août s'est
amusé avec des masques on nous a oubliés
des tests on nous a emmené avec lui dit
on nous s'amuse aujourd'hui avec les
vaccins ce que l'on demande vient
manière très simple en demande ne pas
regretter des demandes de table et pas
sur moi il demande un moment c'est que
priorité à toute personne qui le jettent
toutes les personnes qui désirent se
vacciner puissent accéder aux vaccins au
champion en exemple dans le département
où je vis des personnes de plus de 75
ans ils ont mis deux mois deux ans et
demi à être convoqué j'ai rien que c'est
n'importe quoi
si on veut sortir jeudi au moment de
cette pandémie
il faut un des vecteurs c'est un
d'accélérer la vaccination alors très
court il nous reste quelques secondes
l'exécutif qui n'entend pas non plus
renoncé à son projet de réforme des
retraites
il l'a dit à plusieurs reprises est ce
que cela aussi vous inquiète
évidemment ça nous inquiète parce que je
prends l'exemple la retraite
je suis retraité la requête pour moi
c'est respect pour tous les retraités
si le salaire différé c'est le fruit de
votre travail
aujourd'hui la réponse est qu'elle avait
voulu quand monsieur macron qui a été
initiée par monsieur de le voir elle a
qu'un but c'est de réduire le premier
retraites le ps bien que 2%
arrosez-les vers lui mais ça ce n'est
pas dit qu on va mettre des habillages
sur l'égalité chat
cette année c'est petit mais il ya quand
même des choses si c'est que demain
mercredi une chaîne ont dû difficulté
avant des retraites décentes
parce que le monde de l'emploi des
cadres en difficulté d'une part mais il
ya demain je vais les carrières longues
la mort plus beau mais également il ya
d'autres choses aussi difficile c'est
merci je veux dire en carburant
réversion aux quelques mots le temps qui
nous est imparti est bientôt terminée
écoutez je crois que demain on a
manifesté un pour dire un moment
historique
en froid en achats stocks je veux dire
est à cette forme d'un schisme qui
incarne hannah stoppe aussi je dirais à
celle d'accent qui a le bac également en
soutiennent moi aussi la jeunesse comme
on nous le font actuellement
merci beaucoup j'en salive est d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin je le
rappelle vous êtes président de l'union
confédérale des retraités fo 69